we're told to consider the curve given
by the equation they give this equation
it can be shown that the derivative of Y
with respect to X is equal to this
expression and you could figure that out
with just some implicit differentiation
and then solving for the derivative of Y
with respect to ax we've done that in
other videos write the equation of the
horizontal line that is tangent to the
curve and is above the x-axis pause this
video and see if you can have a go at it
so let's just make sure we're
visualizing this right so let me just
draw a quick and dirty diagram if that's
my y-axis this is my x-axis I don't know
exactly what that curve looks like but
imagine you have some type of a curve
that looks something like this well
there would be two tangent lines that
are horizontal based on how I've drawn
it one might be right over there so it
might be like there and then another one
might be maybe right over here and they
want the equation of the horizontal line
that is tangent to the curve and is
above the x-axis so what do we know what
is true if this tangent line is is
horizontal well that tells us that at
this point dy/dx is equal to zero in
fact that would be true at both of these
points and we know what dy/dx is we know
that the derivative of Y with respect to
X is equal to negative two times X plus
three over four Y to the third power for
any X and Y and so when will this equals
zero well it's going to equal zero when
our numerator is equal to zero and our
denominator isn't so when is our
numerator going to be zero when X is
equal to negative three so when X is
equal to negative three the derivative
is equal to zero so what is going to be
the corresponding Y value when X is
equal to negative three and if we know
that well this equation is just going to
be Y is equal to something it's going to
be that Y value well to figure that
eight out we just take this x equals
negative three substitute it back into
our original equation and then solve for
y so let's do that
so it's going to be negative three
squared plus y to the fourth plus six
times negative three is
equal to seven this is nine this is
negative 18 and so we're going to get Y
to the fourth minus nine is equal to
seven or adding 9 to both sides we get Y
to the fourth power is equal to 16 and
this would tell us that y is going to be
equal to plus or minus two well there
would be then two horizontal lines one
would be Y is equal to two the other is
y is equal to negative two but they want
us the equation of the horizontal line
that is tangent to the curve and is
above the x-axis so only this one is
going to be above the x-axis and we're
done it's going to be Y is equal to two